you super strain of rabies reading  faster that can be contained fetus  super-violent  [Music]  there is no treatment there is no cure  the turns humans into violent predators  the communication is impossible except  for me ready I can speak down language  why I've been bitten but not turn we are  hidden underground in a nuclear silo  we'd searched desperately for patient  zero we could not reverse engineer a  vaccine without patient zero the music's  not affecting him at all  [Music]  you assume we're all the same something  you think smart is evolving you know  anything about patient zero it's only a  matter of time trust me on that  time is a luxury you cannot afford  we've been purged do I look sick to you  yeah and I don't think that we're the  disease really cure to get rid of the  human infection we will continue to  fight those daddy's what we do  I suggest you ask yourself Oh who's  winning what can you see  you